it's our independence there we're here
to get our country back
so we voted remain but now it's it's
here we have no choice so we're going to
get behind it and we're just going to
carry on as normal and we trade within
the EU as a business so we just got to
find a way to do it and get through this
and I mean you know this is important
it's important for everybody whether
you're here in England and Britain and
Scotland Wales and Ireland or whether
you in France or Italy everybody needs
their country and their culture it's a
real backward move for the UK I'm again
very sad about it so it's just the
change it's not a celebration move
wasn't something that we want well I
wanted or we wanted I think but it's
happening so we want to embrace it and
and then look forward this is just the
start of it this is a trial run because
the worst day will be after the
transition year so the 31st of December
will actually be far worse than today
the UK may be leaving the European Union
but there'll be that transition period
until the end of this year most people
will notice little change for the time
being but tough negotiations are about
to begin on the UK's future relationship
with the European Union it's a race
against time the UK and EU have until
the end of 2020 to define their new post
brexit relationship and there's still a
long way to go so what are the issues
that need sorting trade is the biggest
one I think the trade relation between
the two how are we going to do trade
with each other are we going to have
tariffs or are we not going to have
times in the way that we had changed
goods and services that's going to be I
think the biggest thing to do a
successful outcome on this key issue
will depend on the UK agreeing to the EU
calls for a level playing field the EU
wants the UK to stick to EU rules out of
fear that the UK will lower its
standards or profit from unfair
advantages but for British negotiators
being freed of EU rules is one of the
main drivers for brexit so talks will be
tough in my view there
EU has a symmetrically bigger power when
it comes to when it comes to trade each
country they you will be losing one
market the UK will be losing
seven markets there is one element where
I think the UK has got perhaps more of a
say and that is in the financial markets
and that is basically London the city
has served as a major financial hub for
the whole of the EU as the EU doesn't
want to lose that expertise the UK could
use the City of London as a bargaining
chip in the negotiations and then
there's the issue of fishing rights that
could be a stumbling stone on the bumpy
road to brexit taking back control of
British waters was a key brexit campaign
pledge but the UK may have to compromise
if it doesn't want the issue to scupper
chances of finalizing a deal with the EU
the UK leaving in my view was
unjustified and therefore I believe that
it's going to be at the economic cost
for the UK so the closer we can keep
when it comes down to the way we do
trade for example and the better is
gonna be for both of us it's going to be
an extremely tight race to get things
done by the end of the year I'm joined
by David McAllister brexit coordinator
for the European Parliament MEP mr.
McAllister where do you see the red
lines in the upcoming negotiations
well the negotiations are gonna start
presumably at the beginning of March
we're now awaiting for the Commissioner
to present the draft mandate then the
European Parliament will adopt the
resolution the MIL of February and then
finally the council will adopt the
guidelines on the 25th of February we're
under time pressure the UK government
has announced they were under no
circumstances want to prolong the
transition period that means the the
United Kingdom will definitely leave a
single mark and the customs union on the
31st of December that leaves us with
about 8 to 9 months to negotiate our
future relations we will have to
prioritize that's for sure we can't
cover all issues in this short time our
priorities are on the one hand trade
relations and on the other hand a
security cooperation
now the divorce deal was already
difficult enough how difficult would you
say or what do you expect from those
that the negotiations that are upcoming
will there be even more
pickled well of course negotiations are
always challenging and both interests
both sides have different interests but
the UK government and the European Union
have announced that they want to begin
these negotiations in a spirit of
goodwill mutual respect and
understanding both sides want to have a
solid foundation for our future
relations and Britain is leaving the
European Union but the UK will remain
our NATO ally our close political party
and many international organisations and
also the UK's an important trade partner
for us just as the single market is the
most important trade partner for the
United Kingdom so we all have a joint
interest that we should have solid
positive future relations but one thing
is clear a country which leaves the EU
than single market and the customs union
will no longer be in the same position
as a Member State now should a deal be
made by all means or would you say there
are concessions which the EU should not
make in negotiations in the end you must
always have the will to find a
compromise and the consensus and we have
always respected UK position but UK
positions have political consequences if
you voluntarily leave the single market
and the customs union you will have to
face with some of the consequences we
want to have as little friction in our
mutual trade as possible but the
precondition for this is a level playing
field we want a fair competition between
the UK and the European Union that's why
we will insist on a level playing field
our free principles are the integrity of
a single market the customs union cannot
be violated secondly the institutions of
the European Union need to be functional
and thirdly we are very much interested
in keeping the four freedoms of a single
market together before
freedoms of a single market come as a
package they cannot be divided in
defending those principles how concerned
are you about a blame game from the part
of the from the part of the UK if things
shouldn't work out we haven't even
started the negotiations yet and we
should both be optimistic in London as
in Brussels let's get this new
relationship done just as we've got the
withdrawal agreement done both sides
have an interest but we will continue to
closely cooperate and the single market
is the most important market for UK
services and goods so it's also the
British interest to have good relations
with the European single market and the
customs union in the end our new
relationship could be the closest the
European Union has with a third country
when it comes to the width on the one
hand and the depth of our cooperation on
the other hand we're not only talking
about trade we're talking about security
we're talking about energy we're talking
about space we're talking about
fisheries just to name
Arya's the UK and the European Union are
so interconnected and that's no surprise
after 47 years of British membership in
the EU let's get it done for the benefit
of the people and the businesses mr.
mcallister think it's very much indeed
thank you
their Exodus
[Music]